une petite fille en pleurs c'est
toujours émouvant mon cher à la mais
celle là alors quelle était la nature de
son chagrin d'un coût de ses yeux
l'indiquent peut-être ne s'agit pas d'un
chagrin d'amour en fait elle fait
présenter à miss france et figure toi
qu'un sur cinq a suivi attentivement
cette manifestation pour voir ce qui
poussait ces jeunes filles à vouloir
être les plus belles alors ça a commencé
au petit matin pratiquement sous la
direction dans six ans la grande
prêtresse madame de fontenay c'était une
photo de groupe parce que je pourrai
promettre ou demander une jeune fille
qui se présente ce soir à miss france
est restée elle même toujours aussi
gentil d'être souriante et de représente
exactement la jeune fille française
pense sur la morale que physique
[Musique]
c'est qu'ils voient tous milieux le
bruit qui court qu'est ce qui va être
dur on dit que vous en pensez ah oui je
pense aussi qu'elle est belle qu'est ce
que votre bien elle est grande surtout
sa tranche sur lâchement puisque pape
les hôtels sont plus ou moins petit a
donc c'est toujours d'un truc qu'il faut
être grande pour ne pas dire donc non
pas très sûr est gentil me laisser
travailler bien patrice tiens toi bien
nous étions vraiment là au coeur du
problème alors qu'elle était première
réaction le journaliste et bien je veux
dire qu'au début j'ai eu du mal à faire
la différence entre cette présentation
est le salon de l'agriculture
à ce poids là nan sérieusement à leurs
copains de libération de la femme on
peut tout de même un peu s'interroger
parmi les cinquante et une candidate il
y avait une majorité d'étudiantes une
agricultrice une preuve tangible
plastique et quelques autres de
professions diverses mellal planches
s'agit de quoi eh bien il s'agit d'un
test qui va en principe mettre en
évidence leurs qualités morales et
intellectuelles
oui on le voit d'ailleurs qu'est ce que
tu vois rien
[Musique]
à
c'est difficile qu'est ce qu'on vous
demande la main sur le plan esthétique
que vous reconnaissez vous quelques
petits défauts physiques
ok là bas j'avais fait attention à ses
jeunes amis ont débarqué auquel j'ai pas
du tout attendre de l'état nounou du
tangible pour que miss france se soit
pas une femme objet est bien j'estime
qui est tout à fait normal que
s'intéresse à ce qui se passe autour
d'elle parce que le public a tendance à
juger uniquement sur un aspect visuel
mais nous nous recherchons aussi les
qualités intellectuelles morales qui
doivent être exact dix ans un corps sain
dans un esprit un esprit sain dans un
corps sain parce qu est ce que vous avez
lu le livre on a franchement je lis pas
du tout pas du tout c'est que ça compte
ça pourtant ils sont bêtes qui font
médiatique
ah oui là je vous conseille vous avez
quel degré tout balzac dans quelles sont
vos qualités morales à dire pourquoi
vous concourrez pourquoi ce concours
mais il explique ici
d'abord ça me permet de connaître
beaucoup plus de gens et puis peut-être
d'autres pays enfin je ne sais pas
vraiment
celle je vais découvrir d'autres choses
que qu'est-ce que si habitués à
connaître le lendemain soir c'était le
grand moment elle allait concourir
devant de nombreux convives
au menu des hors d'oeuvre ou dessert
mais c'est que s'appuie toujours de ces
exemples remarquer le nôtre ou alors
j'ai moi te demander ton dernier
pronostic en quelque sorte son tiercé
est là aussi je suis plutôt ému parce
qu'on a déjà vu des jeunes filles
ravissantes il est difficile de faire un
choix
alors je crois que le mieux c'est de
laisser la parole au jury tous ceux qui
à des personnalités très importante il
paraît il par exemple il faut qu'on
tienne bien choquant oui j'ai suivi mon
esprit victor ton état continue continue
tu retombes pas les sentiers vous avez
bien mais oui bien ce n'est pas ce qui
est vrai pour l'instant tout va bien et
jacques lavoie qui je suis vraiment pas
bien parce que vous vous rendez vous
jeune fille m'aime pas même pas même pas
mais à force de parler de répondre mais
les chardons jusqu'au mas avec madame de
fontenay je m'étais vraiment à tout de
suite coupé quelques instants plus tard
patrice laffont obtenez l'interview de
sa carrière en obtenant les confidences
du jury j'ai évidemment je pourrais
m'ériger les enfin question de regard
selon quels critères jugés vous énerve
blessé plusieurs parce que c'est
passablement plastique
furent plastique il y à la façon de
parler la face la façon de se comporter
d'une jeune fille dans la vie en général
à mon grand regret des han si vous
voulez on ne les connaît pas
suffisamment pour vous je crois pour
bien les juger en fait c'est une fille
je pense qu'il est appelé à représenter
la france donc vous google de soi
presque mais j'espère qu'elle aura moins
de poids sur les rassurer vous aussi
guide rue les poils manquait à l'appel
voilà c'était vraiment le moment
important moment du défilé ont profité
pour dire qu'il y a trois grand concours
c'est le concours de miss monde de miss
univers et demi c'est international par
des pays différents c'est à dire le
japon l'angleterre et les etats unis
puissent avoir écho aux états unis et la
cia derrière derrière ce qu'elle veut
dire oui madame de fontenay nous a fait
quelques confidences et il semblerait
que ça va très loin il ya des
organisations politiques et des
mouvements on parle même de malhonnêteté
la mls n'était pas présente du tout non
je sais pas si c'était très indicatif
et j'aurais l'air emballé j'avoue du feu
restent sans solution dédiée au tennis
me crame une superbe forêt de jambes
dans lequel on se reposeraient
volontiers volontiers et le défilé final
guy drut lui il met de la sauce dans
tout ça oui ça reste red alimentaire le
jury a continué à délibérer tout
imprégné des images de ces jeunes filles
pendant ce temps les convives continue à
manger sans autre souci que d'attendre
les résultats les résultats nous les
avons attendu nous dans les cuisines
il fallait être sur le court pour avoir
les premières confidences de la part des
membres du jury qui n'ont d'ailleurs pas
voulu en dire très long quel est votre
genre j'aurais voulu une brune parce que
je trouve que il faut réhabiliter les
brunes les blondes ne font plus d'effet
elle gagne davance par espèce d'éclat
qui émane d'elle et on ne regarde pas
c'est en détail les brunes qui absorbent
plus les couleurs
[Applaudissements]
ou de dispense j'ai le plaisir de vous
annoncer que distrayant et les nudistes
[Applaudissements]
et je manque la bise mans mais le 177e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sarrazin c'est vraiment merveilleux
enfin je n'ai pas vraiment exprimé là
tout de suite là vraiment je l'aï
vraiment très très us
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]